hi I'm Erik Bosse said one of the
biggest questions coming out of solo a
Star Wars story is boiler go watch the
movie because I'm about to talk about it
all clear
cool how the hell is Darth Maul in this
movie Haney dead are we before he did
what year is it so yeah at the end of
solo Kyra turns on her boss Dryden Voss
great last name it muses his little
decoder ring to call up a hall of
projection of a hooded figure a surprise
cameo of red skull I mean Darth Maul
he's boss's boss awesome now I'm gonna
explain what this means but first how
did Maul survive the last time we saw
Maul in the movies he appeared to die at
the hands of a young obi-wan Kenobi on
Naboo at the end of the Phantom Menace
hope he won't slice to Manhattan set him
tumbling down one of those big reactor
shafts that are just too common the Star
Wars universe where there's apparently
no OSHA to enforce guardrails
the thing is Maul didn't actually die
there Darth Maul was in arguably one of
the coolest things to come out of these
Star Wars prequels so rather than just
let his story end in episode 1 Lucasfilm
decided to bring back the character in
the animated series Star Wars Clone Wars
and Star Wars rebels Clone Wars explores
side narratives during the events of
attack of the clones and Revenge of the
Sith and the years in between and rebels
is set between Revenge of the Sith and a
new hope technically these storylines
are Canon part of the official Star Wars
history of events but it was never clear
how much the movies would bring elements
of the animated series to the big screen
until now so in Clone Wars we meet a
character named Savage Opress
he's a former wannabes Sith apprentice
of Count Dooku and Darth Maul's brother
and a big twist happens when he finds
Maul on the trash planet of lotho-minor
and yeah it was a pretty big WTF moment
there to Maul reveals to him that he
survived by focusing on his hatred you
know how Palpatine told Vader to focus
his hatred and rage to channel the dark
side of the force into keeping his
broken body intact
well Maul did the same thing with his
rage focused on obi-wan he stopped his
severed body from tumbling down the
shaft and he stowed away in a trash unit
on a ship that got dumped on lotho-minor
where he survived by eating rats and he
built himself these gnarly robotic
spider legs his brother finds him he's a
psychotic hermit who screams a lot but
savage takes small back to their home
planet of Dathomir where their mother
Paulsen uses dark magic to restore mall
sanity and give him these new bipedal
legs from there forward mall walks
around on two robotic legs
that is why in solo when malls hollow
projection stands you can see that he
does have new robotic legs in a mid
section and here Maul is revealed to be
the leader of Dryden bosses crime
organization crimson dawn so how did
mall get here so in clone wars after the
brothers are reunited mall and savage
decide to take over the galaxy
the brothers run into obi-wan a few
times but they fail to kill him obi-wan
actually cuts off about his arm
they also join forces with a group of
Mandalorian Jedi killer it's called the
Death Watch Mandalorians are from
Mandalore they're known for their
warriors and their armor is very well
known it's actually the kind that Boba
Fett wears in Maul now known as just
small no darth Lisa's leaving his SIF
days behind him he's actually credited
as just Maul in the solo credits he
becomes this big crime lord he's taken
over the criminal operations of the
Hutts
and the Black Sun and the Pyke's
syndicate the Pikes were actually
featured in solo they were the group
running the spice mines on Kessel Dryden
mentioned that the crimson dawn had a
delicate alliance with them if they
didn't want to openly shake up anyway in
the animated series malls operation
becomes so big that Darth Sidious tracks
down his former apprentice he kills
Sivaji any torture small but spares his
life deciding to deal with the Jedi
first Maul returns to Mandalore and he's
nearly killed by the Jedi ahsoka tano
but Palpatine Sidious issues Oda 66 and
ahsoka has to take off so Maul is able
to escape and this brings us to the
events of solo in the timeline which is
between Revenge of the Sith and a new
hope and the rule of the Crimson dawn so
what is the crimson dawn the crimson
dawn is a new crime organization that we
heard mentioned for the first time in
solo we can assume that Maul reorganized
his old criminal connections from the
Clone Wars into this new crime cult
that's based around his personality the
name crimson dawn itself evokes small of
course the dawn or resurgence of this
crimson threat red being the color of
his tattoos and his lightsaber now boss
is definitely a wannabe Maul well yeah
that boss but also this one he has red
streaks on his face kind of like he's
trying to go for that look that Darth
Maul has and his weapon is kind of a
smaller version of malls dual-wield
lightsaber but with two blades extended
from the fist
Dryden's lounge also features red
Mandalorian armor that's from the
members of the Death Watch who wore red
armor in support of Maul and clone wars
and a Sith holocron is visible probably
given to him by Maul the symbol of the
crimson dawn shown in the brand on
Kira's wrist and the image drawn by
those Marauders reflects malls history
in a way it's a bisected set of
concentric circles some say it evokes
the circular black Sun symbol or the
Death Star but to me the horizontal line
reflects malls bo staff style lightsaber
and the way he was severed at the
midsection and the circles could reflect
the 360 degree movement of his dual
blades in fact the screenwriter even
mentioned malls martial arts style
fighting method terrace Cassie
they deliberately had Kira fight with a
fluid acrobatic style and then she tells
Han it's what I was taught find your
opponent's weakness and use it this is a
core concept of terrace Cassie of which
Darth Maul was one of the most well
known practitioners and this brings us
to the question why is Maul back
well the screenwriters said that they
wanted to bring Maul back into the
movies because he was one of the most
powerful images to come out of the
prequels and that his face taps into our
primal fears so they called up actor and
stunt performer Rey Park to play an
older version of his character from the
Phantom Menace and instead of Peter
Serafinowicz to do the voice they got
Sam Witwer who voices Maul in the
animated series and if you listen very
closely they snuck in John Williams duel
of the fates into the music of the scene
very cool now since Maul is such a big
character in the animated shows his
return presents a new interesting
direction for these movie characters he
tells Kira to regroup with him on
Dathomir that was his home world from
Clone Wars that I mentioned before and I
suspect Lucasfilm wants to explore more
of malls cribs and doncrime Network if
they ever make a sequel to solo or maybe
the Boba Fett movie that's coming out or
the obi-wan movie that has been rumored
we know from Star Wars rebels where
malls story ends spoiler warning if you
plan to watch rebels ever he tracks down
the old hermit obi-wan Kenobi on
Tatooine and engages him in one last
battle which obi-wan wins holding his
old dying foe in his arms but there's
still a lot of story in between to
explore and Luke's film could overwrite
the rebels storyline if they come up
with a new exciting art form all during
the Galactic Civil War we'll see and
yeah
Maul's lightsaber is once again dual
blade it here even though obi-wan
severed it in the Phantom Menace tool
this could be a nod to rebels which
features the characters the inquisitors
they're sent by the Emperor to kill the
remaining Jedi and Maul they have a
double bladed red lightsaber but I
expect we'll learn more about how Maul
completed his lightsaber if we see him
in any future films but a question I
want to know from you guys which Star
Wars villain are you more excited to see
in future movies kylo Ren and the
Knights of Ren if they ever get into
that or Maul in the crimson dawn
organization comment with your thoughts
down below or tweet me directly Eddy a
vos and follow new rock stars on Twitter
for more updates on her videos like and
share this video subscribe to new rock
stars for more Star Wars stuff including
a more in-depth breakdown of solo for
anything that you might have missed now
excuse me this boss has some mullen to
do Wow wah-wah-wah-wah but today